[Music]
uh welcome back so note to self try and
be balanced here we go now privacy
loving harry and megan have kept a
remarkably low profile since eloping to
california to escape the media spotlight
that is of course if you excuse the book
deals the silicon valley startups the
100 million deal with netflix and the
regular trips to europe we've barely
seen or heard from them at all until now
because my friends are mere 20 months
since pocketing 18 million quid from
spotify yeah i know you can't pay your
bills the first episode of megan's not
at all anticipated podcast series
archetypes was released today and in a
rare moment of introspection megan says
that marrying prince harry made her feel
the negative connotation of the word
ambition whatever that means she also
compares notes on her shared roots with
tennis star serena williams if you must
have a listen
so i don't
ever remember
personally feeling the negative
connotation behind the word ambitious
until i started dating my now husband
and um
apparently ambition is a
terrible terrible thing
for a woman that is according to some
this morning i was saying to harry i
said do you remember one of those i'm
the one for the rest i was about to say
when they said harry's girl is straight
out of compton i was like are they
talking about serena
[Laughter]
i'm not from you know
i'm like i'm not from compton i've never
lived in compton my mom doesn't live in
compton but by the way what's wrong with
compton my girl serena's from there
i know wait wait a minute
now to discuss this i'm joined by
playwright and author bonnie gurion
socialite and aristocat lady victoria
harvey let's start in california uh
victoria welcome to the show um is this
a dig uh to the royal family saying
marrying harry what was it created
negative connotations of her ambition
what does she mean
i mean yes she is definitely playing
that card again and
opening up that door again to possibly
be talking more about the royal family
and her personal experiences i think she
just likes to blame other people and
it's this whole sort of woke victim
playing card that she does a lot
um which she then puts on to
you know serena during this and um
i don't know i find that the whole
interview she's almost trying to mirror
oprah in certain ways the way she talks
to her it's a little condescending
especially when she talks about her
roots um
bonnie um i know you're going to
disagree violently is this just it's all
about victimhood this is what i thought
right i absolutely supported them in
saying i don't want to be in the media
spotlight i want to go and live my life
but when you land and you sign a 118
million dollar deal or whatever isn't
she lucky i mean that's incredible you
should be celebrating this why are you
sitting here complaining about it it's a
good you're not even letting me speak it
might be a good thing but she's making
money from the very thing that she said
forced her out of this country and then
she's using the royal family to slag
them off to make the money and the
people appreciate it
if we don't listen to it we won't hear
it will we you're promoting her
very true point okay very next
yeah very true do you think she's been
unfairly treated by the royal family uh
i don't know
i have no idea can i say something like
that i have no idea and you don't know
do you think she had a plan all along
bonnie a plan to do what
take prince harry from the arms of the
royal family rise from being a zed list
celebrity to a lot more do you think she
planned the whole thing in her head well
how insulting to harry i'm just a very
good person i mean how insulting i mean
seriously this is a grown man he fell in
love with her obviously you fell in love
with your wife i did okay there you go
but you don't think there's anything
about meg and megan that is and i think
a lot of people in this country feel
this they feel i actually think people
in this country were very excited and
then they felt let down
let down by them both do you understand
no i don't feel it i mean first of all
she's a grown woman
uh she was from she's a californian and
lady victoria knows california she acted
exactly as she should have so you're not
surprised by what happened what what
happened in terms of the fact that they
quit the royal family went to america
well she's a grown-up
and they should have actually allowed
her to do her thing and as you said she
was a very good thing
on paper and in fact for this country
and for the royal family it was a cool i
i listen the beauty of life is i don't
actually agree with that at all but
there you go lady victoria what do you
say is it all about victimhood what's
going on
um i i no i mean like i kind of agree
with bonnie that i think i mean i think
it was a quite a calculated move with
megan i think she you know set her
sights on harry from the beginning he
was very vulnerable
um
you know from his childhood and and and
she she latched on to that jump in you
should be victorious
with respect with respect
we do know everything about harry you
know because he's been a public figure
but how can we sit here and psycho
analyze this guy i mean that's wrong
that's literally but i i just thought i
i think that that is the way he comes
across
but that's not the same thing is
but her personality is very overpowering
come on don't do that to him this guy is
growing he looks like what are you doing
since he's been with her he was a proper
man all right let's make it more simple
i haven't got a lot of time i'd love to
have more bonnie do you understand
people in this country's frustration
with meghan markle because there is huge
frustration
they'd be frustrated they'd be glad she
wasn't french
that's not they'd be really frustrated
no i think there is an element of in
this country who don't actually like
foreigners
even though even though the royal family
is german completely agree final word
from you victoria what do you say i
haven't got long
what the final thing that i want to say
about her podcast
good well that about sums it up uh i
won't be listening you might listen i
mean everybody everybody has an opinion
about harry and megan and they are
entitled that opinion thank you to
bonnie thank you to lady victoria uh
will i be watching or listening to a
podcast no will you
i don't listen to anybody's pocket
brilliant i love her right that is it
from me what a happy lady you are that's
it from me
you